- Good morning, believe nation.
Today's message is go for it.
Over to you, Rich DeVos.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Starting at the bottom at
Amway is wherever you are today.
Everybody starts at the bottom.
And there is no advantage
to starting 10 year ago
as opposed to starting today.
In fact, it's better
today than it was then.
Our products are better.
Our line is better.
Our plan is better.
It's more proven.
It's a better a plan today
than when we started.
And sometimes there are no
answers as to whether you want
to be in business or would
like to be in business.
You just got to put your
toe in the water, you know.
If you're going to wait
'till you know everything,
you'll never do anything.
And you always say, well,
I got to check some more.
I'm going to do a little more research.
Go ahead, just keep going,
and you'll never get in a business.
If you're going to go swimming,
you got to get wet, you know.
And then you find the people
who've got a hot button
for having a business of their own
and want to do their own thing
and like the chance to
build a big business.
Well, you got to have that dream.
That's why the people
talk about having a dream.
You got to have a little bit of dream.
And then you say, I'll
go out and get customers.
I got a big chance to
build a really big thing.
I'm going to go out
and get some customers.
When you start something
new, it's not easy.
But life is easier when you got a business
and you're making some money.
Makes it a little easier.
So stick with it.
Find a way through it.
Just find out an answer.
It works, folks.
This business works for those who work it.
- There comes a point in time in your life
where you just need to decide
you're going to go for it.
In a lot of things in life,
not just in starting a business.
In asking that guy or girl out.
In deciding to get married or not.
In saying yes to that opportunity or not.
At some point, you have
to decide to go for it,
and it's hard because you want
to have perfect information.
Right, you want to have
it all figured out.
You will never have perfect information.
By the time you get perfect information,
you will have missed your opportunity.
And so if you want to have
success as an entrepreneur,
you need to jump in before
you have the complete picture.
And you adjust, and you
figure things out as you go.
I lost a 40 million dollar
deal in my first business
because I was too late.
Because I was planning and planning
and planning and planning.
And not doing enough.
I still end up selling my company,
but I didn't get the 40 million dollars
that the other guy got.
And I don't want that to happen to you.
And it already is happening to you.
That's the frustration.
That's the problem.
You have already had genius level ideas
that other people are makin' money off of
because you were tinkering
and thinking and strategizing
and planning day after day after day
and not actually doing anything.
This person when out there
and made tons of money
and had a huge impact off of your idea.
Why can't that be you?
And don't complain.
It's not because you
didn't have resources.
It's not because of whatever
reason you're telling yourself.
It's because you didn't take action.
You got to go out and do it.
And you don't need to go all in.
You don't need to burn the boats.
You need to take out a
huge mortgage on your house
or a massive loan that puts you way back.
You can start smaller, but start.
Do something.
As soon as you get an idea for something
that you want to test that
might be something big
that you might have this big passion for,
then try immediately, today, right now.
Take some small action towards
moving that ball forward
and figure out do I want
to keep doing this or not?
Does it make me come alive?
Am I passionate about this?
Is there a path to
adding value for people?
Or not.
A lot of the things that
you have in your head,
once you start actually doing it,
you don't like, and you quit.
That's great.
And you move on to something else.
But you can't actually
get to the finish line.
You can't have that big impact.
You can't be the person
that you know you can be
until you actually go for something.
So do it.
Today.
Believe.
So the question today is, I'm curious
what have you been holding back on?
What's the thing that
you haven't gone for yet
that you want to, that you've
been holding yourself back on?
And hopefully, by writing it
down in the comments below,
it'll force you to actually
do something on it today.
Make a powerful decision.
Write it down.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Jodi Holland.
Jodi, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Hey, believe nation, for those of you
who want a little more
motivation, insight,
and expertise on going forward,
here are some bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- I believe desire and
will to win is everything.
I don't know why I'm like I am,
but my butt's always burning.
There's always somethin'
say, Art, dadgummit,
you're supposed to go for it.
Or, Art, dadgummit, you're
supposed to be somebody.
You're supposed to make a
difference with your life.
What does the $500,000 a year person do
the $50,000 a year doesn't do?
You look at the outside and
study those two individuals.
Everything seems to be the same.
They both are the same sex.
They both are the same age.
They have the same training,
the same positions,
the same contract, the
same fringe benefits.
They both are successful.
They work hard.
They're good family people.
Make tough commitments.
But what's the difference?
What does the $500,000 a year person do
the $50,000 a year doesn't do?
He pays the price a little bit more.
He works hard and a little bit more.
He's loyal to the company
a little bit more.
He bleeds and a little bit more.
He makes money and a little bit more.
He saves money and a little bit more.
If you want to win in these United States,
you got to be tough and you can't quit.
The last thing I'll
talk to you about today
in building this winning edge is folks,
if you want to win in business,
you got to be a leader.
Leadership is everything.
You show me anything in
these United States that win,
I'll show you a leader at work.
You show me a successful
church, Boy Scout troop,
club, football team,
business, I'll show you
somethin' run by leader.
See, I thought at one time in my life
you had to be smart to win.
I used to have these smart people
that dress so pretty and talk so pretty
and use these big words.
They just intimidated me, and I said, Art,
you can't ever be that good.
Why don't you just throw
in the towel and go on back
and coach football for a living.
And I found two things
out about smart people.
I think it's almost
impossible for a smart person
to win in business in America today.
Because I find smart people
spend their whole lifetime
figuring things out.
They always trying to
figure out an easier way
and a quicker way.
(crowd laughs)
And another thing I found
out about smart people
is they just don't get
around to doing nothing.
And see somebody like Art Williams.
Everybody said, well, he can't do it.
Somebody like that can't do it.
But he does it.
See, folks, I want you
to know almost everybody
in America almost does enough to win.
They almost get there.
They almost over the hump.
They almost have it going.
They almost in everything they do.
Almost is a way of life to
almost everybody in America,
but the winners do it.
What do they do?
They do whatever it takes
to get the job done.
They do it and do it and do it
and do it and do it
until the job gets done.
And then they talk about how great it is
to be somebody they're proud of.
We need leaders in America who can do it.
If you want to become somebody, do it.
If you want to go in
business for yourself, do it.
If you want to become
financially independent, do it.
I hear too much talk
in these United States.
Everybody can talk a good game.
We need people in America who can do it.
I go all over this
country with AL Williams,
and I have people say,
Art, you can count on me.
Wonderful, just do it.
Or, Art, I guarantee you
this is my last stop.
I'm going to win now.
Super duper.
Just do it.
Or, Art, if I can just have one good month
and get the ball going, I
know I could make it big.
Super, just do it.
Or, Art, if I can just pay off this debt,
I could really go.
Great, just do it.
Or, Art, if I could just sell my house.
Do it.
But houses ain't sellin'.
Do it anyway.
(crowd laughs)
Or, Art, I'm not makin' any money.
What can I do?
You just do it.
Do what, Art?
You do it and do it and do it.
Or, Art, I guarantee I'm
going to win this contest.
Super duper, just do it.
Or, Art, I'm over the hump now.
Watch my smoke.
Great.
Just do it.
Or, Art, I want to make
it so bad I can taste it.
What do I do?
You just do it.
Or, Art, I'm a vice president now.
Can I quit doin' it?
No.
(crowd laughs)
Or, Art, I don't know if
I can keep on keepin' on.
I'm really hurtin'.
What do I do?
You just do it.
Do what, Art?
You do it and do it and do it.
Or, Art, all my life I've
wanted to be somebody important.
Well, do it then.
Or, Art, I'm going to save
money, so I never have
to go through this again.
Great.
Just do it.
Or, Art, I don't feel like
I've had enough training.
What do I do?
You just do it.
Or, Art, my manager don't give me no help.
What do I do?
You just do it.
Or, Art, you don't understand.
I was Mr. Everything in my former company.
You don't mean I have to start
off down here at the bottom
and do it, do ya?
Yep, you really got to do it.
(crowd laughs)
Art, what's the primary difference
between winners and losers?
The winners do it.
They do it and do it and do it and do it
until the job gets done.
And then they talk about how great it is
to finally have achieved somethin' unique
and how glad that they
are that they didn't quit
like everybody else
and how wonderful it is
to finally be somebody they're proud of
and make a difference with their life.
- Kind of cliche, but just do it.
A lot of time is spent
thinking about something.
- Oh, yeah.
- And talking about it.
- Yeah.
- But when you actually
get something down,
whether on paper or in code
or, you know, in front of someone,
that's when things start happening.
You're going to make a lot of mistakes,
but the important thing
is that you make decisions
and you keep moving forward.
But you have to get it out there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And you have to start.
And you have to be brave
enough to take the criticism.
I always go back to the
punk movement of the 70s.
People would get out.
They'd be on the street.
They'd start.
- Cause you were a teenager back then.
- Yeah, and well (laughs)
they would be learning
in front of people and like they'd get out
on the street, and it's their
first time with a guitar.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And they're learning how to play,
and they're getting better
and better and better.
- Yeah.
- And I think it's really important
to just get it down.
Do it.
- [Interviewer] Just do it.
- Edit, edit, edit edit.
- It's one thing to philosophize
about training strategies
and to, you know, compare this philosophy
versus another, you know.
Or argue about, you know,
how many grams versus
how many grams is, but
then there's something
to be said for doing the damn thing.
You know, just do it.
You know, stop talking.
Stop tryin' to sound smart.
You meet these people
that want to engage you
in these conversations and one-up
the professional body builder.
Ah, I know more about nutrition than,
I'm like well, dude, I mean,
I'm not, straight, I'm not where I'm at
because I know more about nutrition
than everybody else on the planet.
You know, in fact, I daresay
that the top bodybuilding
athletes that are on stage
are not the man on stage,
make a right here, because they know more
about training science and nutrition
than the average person
sitting in the audience.
A lot of times the
difference between the person
in the audience and the person
that's on stage doing it
is the use of the knowledge.